[Music]
a lavender spray
lavender was supposed to freshen homes
instead
it killed two
people what the [ __ ]
wait what the [ __ ] is happening was
there a lighter held in front of it
a month's long cdc investigation
revealed an aromatherapy spray imported
from india
and sold at walmart was contaminated
with deadly bacteria but it was just
that they're like they accidentally put
cyanide in there
it's okay you're from hunter i'm
actually not indian
you're from huntington beach
so on july 12th a five-year-old boy in
georgia arrived at an emergency
department following several days of
sickness vomiting weak sore throat heart
rate unusually fast
fever spiked to more than 102 degrees
typically
doctors admitted the child to the
hospital to keep an eye on him and help
keep him properly hydrated that night
his breathing became labored and he
tested positive for covid
doctors immediately started a typical
treatment for the infection including
steroids and anti-volatile so covid came
through a lavender spray no because i
heard bacteria that was like you also
got covered yeah you got a combo oh
did he get it at the hospital no
so no covey next to blade plug-ins
he did not get better
within four days of hospitalization he
died [ __ ] that sucks an autopsy later
detected the coronavirus in his lungs
and upper airways but also showed
something surprising bacteria called
berculderia
pseudomalay in the boy's lungs liver
spleen and brain
that finding would eventually lead
investigators to solve three other cases
of the same infection that occurred
earlier in the year in three different
states
details of all four cases were published
recently
so basically
this guy
uh
gets this really really unusual
situation and then they launch an
investigation and then the people from
cdc go into the investigation and then
they have to go through this really
rigorous test of everything in the house
because they didn't know where this
particular bacteria that is not native
to america and it's not usually found in
america so they had to check everything
so they tested everything after months
they finally found this aromatherapy
spray and the [ __ ] crazy thing is
that same aromatherapy spray was the
same thing that was in three other
separate homes that led to deaths as
well so how many other aromas therapy
sprays were was it organ contaminated
it was organic
the investigators discovered the
bacteria in an aromatherapy room spray
in the house the product the lavender
and chamomile scent of better homes and
gardens essential oil infused
that's a big brand
with gemstones had been imported from
india and sold at 55 walmart stores and
it's at walmart as well as on the
walmart's website i'm going to repeat
that just in case anybody has purchased
that
better homes and gardens essential oil
infused aromatherapy room spray with
gemstones from walmart if you have
purchased this there has been
contamination of a bacteria from india
that leads to this type of potential
that's [ __ ]
and then they said when we got the first
confirmation it came as a huge relief
because then they were able to
understand how come other people didn't
get sick and die from it well that's the
thing people that bought this particular
spray were feeling these symptoms and
apparently so far that's that's the
thing too is that
they're [ __ ] lucky that they decided
to look into it to that level because
who knows how many people did die from
it and it's just being attributed to
something else because if it's if it was
distributed that widely so many people
had to bought this yeah for sure so what
happened did a prankster take a dookie
inside of the essential oil
yes
no i haven't i have no idea pranks are
from maybe essential soy indian
prankster come on man they got youtube
out there they got youtube prank video
he got in the tank had sex with a bat oh
true hey that does happen
so true
and that's why they have bacteria and
covid
all four patients whose cases are
detailed in a new report initially had a
wide range of vague symptoms such as
fatigue shortness of breath
fever nausea etc and then one case
involved a four-year-old girl in texas
whose family sought medical attention
for her several times after she'd been
vomiting and had a fever of more than
103 degrees you're trying to make the
house smell nice but lavender is bad
though fresh laundry that's the one you
want to get no lavender yeah don't get
lavender on this [ __ ] i get fresh
laundry every time it smells [ __ ]
good or oh dude you want it you want
something that's not glade because that
glaze is a little more expensive you get
the airwick you get the apple cinnamon
you're good to go apple cider i like the
fruity stuff don't even worry about it i
don't like the flower stuff sounds like
fall every time budget conscious aroma
therapy tips that's not white people
[ __ ] apples are growing all over the
united states
cinnamon all over them
and cinnamon fuji they got some fuji
apples it's borderline pumpkin spice is
what i'm saying it's almost
the
what kind of what kind of spray do you
use
oh [ __ ] man i don't i don't use anything
i spray everything with excess therapy
sprays it the oils that you [ __ ] put
in your humidifiers and [ __ ] and you let
that sucker go out in your room or it's
like those little jars with the uh with
the sticks out of it and the liquid
inside oh i love it those are they'll
smell good comes in a variety of you
know
you're right i should show this image
again
in the [ __ ] up lavender thing this is
the particular product that was on
walmart what do you do with that i'm
glad i just make the house smell nice
this one is an actual spray like a
cologne type thing has like a little
squirter at the top and stuff like that
who would think that [ __ ] could kill you
like that for example one of the uh one
of the victims like their their parents
were just spraying it like on like bed
pillow shoes and stuff just to make sure
it smelled and was because the thing is
sometimes people have that understanding
of belief in things like essential oils
right so they want to put that in close
proximity
and the problem is this particular
bacteria or what causes these these
things are also like you know
what's the word have you heard about
what kills cats and [ __ ] essential oils
be careful out there yeah really all
essential oils well no but they're the
but that had that's often coral the oils
don't sound very essential
there are a subset of people that use
essential oils and they use it for
healing anything everything yeah but
you've got to be careful around pets
yeah do you think that when this happens
that the um
underground market for selling
whatever's left goes up for like
assassins
um
that is a dark ass thought and i like it
assassins are like okay just give me the
usual lavender and then they're like
excuse me
how much is it right now are you excuse
me
what happened
oh the news got out wow
okay good price pumped i guess i'll take
uh some rope then thanks
the overhead of my career
[Laughter]
i'll get the chloroform uh
that's crazy so uh scary too because the
scariest thing about this story is i
feel like we were millimeters away from
dodging how the news could have
sensationalized that into being another
coveted related like oh now kovid kills
you this way through essential oils
thank god there was a good scientist in
that lab that went no it was actually
this and it's from india so look at all
the indians in your life
walmart so maybe walmart or the walmart
family is suppressing that you know
you only want essential indians which
ones are the essential indians oh my i'm
negligible bollywood you let me go and
then tech giants hey let me tell you
something the last frame of shank change
wouldn't happen if not for you i think
you're pretty essential thank you very
much yeah yeah thank you thank you bye
city blues
[Laughter]
my boy blue
are they saying like is this some kind
of like
new bacteria that doesn't exist in the
u.s it's just not common or familiar
here which is why they had confident
room spray they had to bring in the
actual like cdc investigation team uh
and at the end of the day we're in a
generation i wonder if that's rampant in
india though like are people like
constantly being affected by that here's
the thing with india
[ __ ] they got so many crazy ass
bacterias they're just like immune to
everything
like like if we go there like and you
drink a water water out of a faucet like
you you just you die that's what tessa
was telling us but like vacate to the
diseases
yeah well my my grandma lived to 96 and
she was drinking out of a well oh my
she's like you can't [ __ ] with me
because when maggots come in here i kill
them
that's free when [ __ ] when tapeworm
comes in they go oh who can live here
and then they leave
they dip out her immune system is just
like [ __ ] you get the [ __ ]
you know that's what i heard like uh we
have a lot of autoimmune diseases right
in the u.s and like um we have a lot of
like weird uh diseases where the immune
system attacks itself like ourselves
and they're saying it's because like
we're used to dealing with more bacteria
viruses all that stuff and when it has
nothing to work on then it [ __ ] you up
man
so maybe we should all go to india and
drink from the well just a little bit
just a little while or maybe there's a
way to do it gradually like is there a
way where we can slow down are there
wells that are arranged in a row or
there's a company that just gives you
doses over here micro micro dosing
indian water macro dose bacteria bro
come on yeah cause
indian babies don't come out and be like
i'm ready for the world right maybe they
got to get like indian titty milk or
like something it's like probiotics bro
getting them ready to live in the indian
world i guess it's like it's like shots
right it's like taking a flu shot is not
necessarily taking like something to
protect you against it but rather it's
giving you a small dose of it yeah like
that's what vaccine is so we just need
like small doses like brad pitt and
[ __ ] world war z of everything and
then we'll be [ __ ] sorry are you a
legend at eating spicy foods
not a legend at all oh no
but okay here's the other thing about
that though is in india they're not
using home gardens lavender scent [ __ ]
it's just getting made there
it's just getting made there and sent
overseas immediately
keep them back for a reason
what do you do to keep an indian house
scented oh and you just cook indian food
and it and it smells that sounds like
the setup of a perfectly good joke by
the way
sorry sorry i didn't know 90s racist
joke
i don't know what the punchline would be
it is a 90s racist joke
what's the setup again
what do you do to keep an indian house
scented
[Music]
[Laughter]
i mean according to joe it gets steamy
that's the hacky that's the hacky open
mic line
and everyone's like oh no
oh yeah hey who said that oh my mom did
okay yeah
i mean anthony jumped on that curry joke
real quick
oh did you say that
it's pungent am i being racist well yeah
sorry no it's fine
he goes well yeah
you know i heard like in tropical areas
like there's more variants and disease
and bacteria and things like that
because they can
live
under those conditions and and like yeah
i guess it's it's just a thriving
because they can they can culture and
just turn into other [ __ ] yeah they
don't they like live doormat in like
cold places or like there's just yeah is
that hot and humid mm-hmm
hot and spread
nice and moldy you know but i love
tropical that's my favorite kind of
weather
[Music]